i'm telling you and if any
outside you better pronto get that
jacket
and make sure that you're warm before
you get out there because once you do
and if you're not dressed for it you're
going to find out in a hurry how chilly
it is on this friday morning gorgeous
though
beautiful blue skies as we look outside
side to uh
the spring mountains where we've had
those gusts at 35 miles an hour
overnight it's 45 but it feels like 35
with those winds starting to see just a
very slight break
in those winds right now about five
degrees cooler than we were yesterday at
this hour those north winds
all over the valley and up in the
mountains and even out at
the lake in the river and we expect that
to last all day where we have that wind
advisory in place
until four o'clock this afternoon red
rock very bumpy too if you're taking
friends or family out there to do some
sightseeing
gorgeous skies though these north winds
always clean up the air
60 degrees today that's it that's a few
degrees warmer than thanksgiving
and then we'll get into some mid 60s on
sunday or last weekend of november some
clouds around monday
and we'll start off december right
around 60
61 degrees into next week so
bundle up everybody happy shopping if
you're headed out for a black friday
but come back because we're not done yet
on good day las vegas
we'll return in just a couple of minutes